there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
march to test for ourselves this is the
kimchi chic beauty teddy kim palette in
the boyfriend color story it's an eye
shadow and face palette i went in with
the blush and highlighter first and i
loved them they were really buildable
and went on so smoothly moving on to the
eyeshadow you do get a nice mix of
mattes shimmers and glitters i think all
of these colors work together really
well i went in with a couple of mattes
first and they blended great then i
played around with these shimmers and
glitters again these applied great
they're super shiny and reflective but i
did get fallout with the glitter so i
recommend using a primer overall i was
very happy with this palette and another
fun thing about it is that it actually
comes with stickers so you can customize
your little bear my bear definitely goes
to euphoria high but yes i love this i
can see this being really good for
travel although maybe a little bit hard
to pack
the rose inc skin enhanced luminous
tinted serum is one of the weirdest
products i've seen in a while it's
basically a skin tint with this serum
base that's filled with pigment beads
that give you some coverage they say to
apply this with a brush to break up and
spread those pigment beads so that's
what i did i really went into this
thinking it was just gonna look like an
oily mess on me but then i noticed how
good it was making my skin look the
coverage is light but it's just enough
that it gives this my skin naturally
looks like this with no effort kind of
look i typically hide any imperfections
on my face with a more full coverage
foundation but this made my skin look so
smooth and dewy that i didn't feel like
i needed more but this product really
shocked me not only in how good it
looked but also and how good it made me
feel this is the elf cookies and dreams
lip gloss in cookie dreams and yes it is
a black lip gloss with a bunch of pretty
blue and silver glitter throughout i
tried this out on my bare lips first and
i didn't love it because you can see in
the areas where the gloss tends to pool
a bit more it has this very obvious
bluish black tint that looked a little
odd on me but then i applied this over
my favorite lip liner and i immediately
understood why people liked this so much
oh my god it looked incredible over lip
liner it kind of gave the liner a deeper
look that just worked so well and the
formula of the gloss itself is actually
really nice for the four dollar price
point i'm definitely hanging on to this
to layer over other lip products i was
so excited to try this huda beauty easy
bake loose baking and setting powder in
cherry blossom i had to get this baby
version because the full size was
completely sold out it's a baby pink
setting powder that's supposed to really
brighten up the under eyes i just
applied my concealer like normal and
went in with a little puff that comes
with it this puff is nice but the shape
was really annoying to use so i did use
a brush to get into the hard to reach
spots this powder does have a very
strong floral scent that was actually
giving me a headache so i had to remove
it after a few minutes it recommends
that you leave it on for five but i
couldn't take it anymore i'm sorry i did
see a slight brightening effect but it
wasn't blowing me away i could still see
my dark circles peeking through a bit i
do however think that this is a nice
powder formula it's really smoothing and
super finely milled but they need to get
rid of the scent maybelline just dropped
its super stay vinyl ink long wear no
budge liquid lip color this is a long
wearing lipstick that's meant to stay
shiny which really got my attention you
have to shake it for five seconds then
apply when i first started applying i
got nervous because it looked really
patchy but i got full coverage when i
added another layer and it surprisingly
felt lightweight on the lips i kissed my
hand to check for transfer and there
definitely was some i did a test wearing
my mask and saw some transfer there too
and then i took a sip of my drink and
saw minimal transfer there as well even
though i was getting a little transfer
and most of the shine was gone the
lipstick itself still looked super
bright and it didn't move anywhere so i
was happy with that this is the dior
backstage flash perfector concealer i
think the main thing that's special
about this is that it has a brush
applicator instead of a doe foot
applicator so that's supposed to be
easier to blend in i still had to use my
sponge for blending but i did like how
easy application was with the brush
although i wouldn't say it was any
easier than a regular doe foot
applicator the formula itself is really
nice the coverage is more on the medium
side but it covered enough i like this
concealer but i wouldn't tell you to go
run and get it it's just a nice
concealer with a high-end name on it
the beautyblender power pocket puff is
basically a double-sided velour puff so
the pink side is for powder application
and the tan side is for blending the
powder and makeup it does pick up a lot
of product i tried to tap off as much as
i could but it still deposited a lot of
powder it is described as a tool you can
use for baking the under eye area so
maybe that's why the shape does make it
easy to use and i liked how it has this
little strap on it that can be used on
either side after leaving the powder on
for a bit i used the tan side to blend
it in and it wasn't getting rid of all
the powder so i did use a brush to dust
off the excess
i noticed that my under eye area looked
really smooth smoother than when i set
the area with my normal sponge the lines
under my eyes weren't as defined this is
the new mac mac stack mascara and it's
supposed to be super volumizing which i
love what i don't love is a plastic
mascara brush which this has but i was
still excited to try this when i first
started applying i immediately hated the
feeling of the brush on my eye it's a
little too spiky for someone like me
with pretty sensitive eyes i noticed an
instant lift and volume with my lashes
which are naturally pretty straight i
did another coat and loved how this made
my lashes look they look long and full
without looking clumpy i don't know if i
can justify 28 for mascara but this one
is so good i might have to splurge on it
every now and then
[Music]
[Applause]